brought to you by Tom Clancy's Rainbow
six siege siege the day in stores now
rated M for Mature Rainbow six siege is
a game that rewards team planning and if
these sports has taught us anything
planning starts at team selection a well
chosen team will be well-positioned to
well and truly stick it to their
opponents so here are the defensive
roles that will serve you well in your
mission to withstand any siege damages
though it can take a while for bullets
to start flying the knowledge war is
waged right from the get-go information
warriors can help your team in two very
important endeavors a learning stuff and
B stopping the other team from learning
stuff deploying boots electronic jammer
early can put a halt to the rolie polie
drone parade leave your enemies in the
dark and make them burn valuable time
searching for you put the jammer at one
choke point and cover the other yourself
shooting any sausage rolls that come
your way once that phase is over smash
any drones deactivated by your jammer
then pick it up and reposition it you
can prevent remote breaches and stop
further drone shenanigans as you tighten
up around the objective now that the
enemy is enroute get everyone's favorite
looky-loos pulse on the scene if you see
some telltale hearts hanging out on the
other side of a wall use the ping system
to put a marker on the wall and then
tell your teammates to open fire who
says attackers have to be the ones to
open hostilities no matter what position
you're defending there are a lot of ways
the attackers can get at you this is
where the booby trap is come in their
gadgets help shut down avenues so you
can watch other avenues with your gun
ideally something like captain's
explosive tripwires will kill an
attacker outright allowing you to set it
and forget it but they do leave a bolt
through the wall that can be spotted and
dealt with by savvy enemies be sure to
position yourself close enough to your
traps to hear when they are being
dismantled so you can respond
appropriately the audio in Rainbow six
siege conveys key information about
everyone's whereabouts so listen up and
stay as quiet as you can
another booby-trap trick is turning
regular old reinforced barricades and
barbed wire into zapping reinforced
barricades and barbed wire with bandits
shock battery one of these inside a wire
nest will turn it into a barbeque for
any careless little scout rolls and make
it a pain for any headstrong attackers
once you hear the enemy's start to deal
with your booby traps it's time to
activate your sleeper agent this is the
operator that you sent out into the
field to lie in wait to pounce on the
attacking team once they were focused on
your defenses you did that right you
don't want to pull this move every time
and it may sometimes be a suicide
mission but you can usually catch some
of the attacking team unaware and create
a nasty distraction to allow your
teammates to strike and sneak you as a
defender it's important to use all of
the weapons in your arsenal and that
includes the clock the attacking team is
on a timer so the more seconds you can
burn the closer you get to victory and
the more pressure you'll put on the
attackers to make rash mistakes this is
the motto of clock burners like smoke
his remote detonated gas traps are a
great area denial tool they are the
second thing you should throw into a
freshly blown breach with c4 being the
first and they make great cover when
you're retreating back towards your
objective
you can also burn time by simply staying
alive longer and being the threat that
slows your enemy's progress rook can
improve your whole team's survivability
with his bag of armored jackets and
docks revival syringe can turn a bad
situation into a slightly less bad
situation provided you or your down
teammate is only suffering from a flesh
wound and not you know death shooting a
teammate to revive them is a big
improvement on scurrying up to them
yourself as revived opportunities are
often traps laid by attackers who still
have eyes on your downed Ally
heed the lessons of Saving Private Ryan
folks the last key members of a
defensive powerhouse are the gun
shooters I mean everyone needs to be a
gun shooter if you're gonna stand a
chance
but this tachanka fellow well
to say he takes a gun shooting to a
whole different level
his deployable mounted gun will chew up
attackers and destructible cover with
equal enthusiasm so if you can get pulse
to scout the attackers entry point and
set up quickly you are the man of the
hour
well minute okay more like 20 seconds
this mounted gun puts a huge target on
to chacas position making him incredibly
vulnerable to alternate firing angles or
grenades make your loud and deadly debut
then pack the thing up if you've got a
moment or just get the heck out of there
the more that the attackers feel
threatened by you the better stay calm
communicate with your teammates and
don't just freak out when the breach
charges start going off all around you
with a properly stacked team the odds
are ever in your favor
tell us your preferred role in the
comments below and stand tall against
any and all sieges
rattling historian hospital ward